what i want to do in this video is try
to understand how one company can buy
another company or could merge it with
another company by using its stock so we
have a situation here where company a is
acquiring company b for 60 million
dollars in a's shares what we'll see is
it's not going to exactly be 60 million
dollars it'll depend on where companies
a company a shares trade right now
they're trading at 30 a share so in
order to make this transaction happen in
a shares what would happen is is that a
says look i need to raise the equivalent
of 60 million dollars in shares or i
need to create the equivalent of 60
million dollars in shares if each of my
shares right now on the market are worth
thirty dollars a share then i can do
that by creating or issuing two million
shares so company a here is going to
create another two million shares
they're going to create another 2
million shares and if they wanted to do
it as a cash transaction they could take
these shares and sell them into the
market do a secondary offering and then
hopefully raise 60 million dollars in
cash and then use that cash to buy
company b but this is a share offering
they're not going to do it with cash
they're going to directly give assuming
company b shareholders agree to this
they're going to give the shares
directly to company b's shareholders in
exchange for essentially getting control
of these shares right over here so
they're going to take these 2 million
shares which right now on the market
look to be worth 60 million dollars and
they're going to give them to all of
company b's shareholders in exchange for
all of company b's existing shares so
what's going to happen is company a is
going to give 2 million shares of
company a
to the shareholders of company b and in
exchange company b will give all of the
shareholders of the of company we will
give their shares to company a so they
will give
so or their shares of company b i should
say company b's shareholders are going
to give all of their 1 million shares in
company b in exchange for those two
million of company a so what's going to
happen is each of these shareholders of
company b are going to get two shares of
company a for every one share of company
b
so they're going to get two shares
two shares of a
for
every
share
of b they own and that makes sense
economically because right now on the
market
let's say that it's trading at fifty
dollars a share it has a 50 million
dollar mark market cap by offering a 60
million dollars in share they're
offering a premium this is what will
kind of convince all of their
shareholders to maybe say hey this is a
pretty good deal i'm getting 20 percent
above the market price
and when you get two shares in exchange
for your 150 share you're getting two
shares that are right now trading at
thirty dollars a share so it seems like
a good deal for you i can exchange
something worth fifty dollars for two
things worth thirty or essentially
exchange something worth fifty for
something worth sixty dollars i'm going
to take it and if they do take it then
what's essentially going to happen is is
that
those 1 million shares are going to be
put onto the asset side of company a's
of company a's balance sheet or maybe we
could just put that company b is now
here because all of their shares are
here it's not completely owned and the
company was able to do that by issuing
these shares the other option they could
have issued they could have sold those
shares in the market raised 60 million
dollars then given the 60 million
dollars directly to the company b
shareholders and then it would have had
the exact same effect